donc je ne vais pas le faire, c'est au marié que
mon meilleur ami doit t'avoir après, donc je
suppose que c'est tout, je veux dire, tu connais la règle, je le
fais, je pensais
juste que ce que je pensais que nous aimions
peut-être bien s'entendre, non, je veux mettre la
balle  le toast pour avoir tout ça euh,
qu'est-ce que tu fais exactement bienvenue chez the
best man Inc. Je fournis des services de témoin
pour les gars comme toi qui manquent dans de tels
domaines hé, je regarde les filles quand tu en as besoin d'
une ou deux, j'ai besoin de sept, tu manges
bien sept  vous parlez, c'est ce dont nous
plaisantons et dans moins de deux semaines, aidez-
moi, je ne sais pas quoi
faire d'autre, d'accord, si je fais cela, vous devez
comprendre qu'il s'agit strictement d'une
relation commerciale, vous n'achetez pas
de  nouvel ami, vous embauchez un témoin, je l'
ai compris, je suppose que vous m'avez inventé un nom,
BIC Mitchum, pas question de Kate. Hé
mesdames, que se passe-t-il, mon nom est grand,
je suis BIC Mitchum et j'adore les bonbons que BIC
Mitchum peut avoir.  tout ce que tu veux,
d'accord, j'aime ça
Dieu a créé un monde en sept jours, nous devons
faire beaucoup plus en beaucoup moins
de temps, qui sont ces gens veulent que je me fasse
grandir, ces gars ne peuvent pas être mes
garçons d'honneur, on dirait que tout le casting
de  Les Goonies ont grandi et sont devenus des violeurs, c'est
mon travail de vous faire bien paraître le
jour de votre mariage, c'est pourquoi nous sommes ici, cela
s'appelle une course à sec, vous pouvez cacher un gros cul
dans un pantalon ample mais vous ne pouvez pas cacher un mauvais
danseur, vous avez demandé comment un  une fille comme Gretchen
pourrait tomber amoureuse de moi j'ai dansé et touche-
moi hein bon chien
oh mes femmes m'aiment oh mes femmes m'aiment elles
sont aussi talentueuses ces gays en ce
moment nous sommes des messieurs impeccables quelle
heure est-il qu'un sous-écran cherche juste un
groupe  des gars que j'ai jamais vu Oh trois
balles
le comptent sacré Je veux que ma vraie vie soit
aussi amusante que celle pour laquelle j'ai payé hé allons
écrire un peu d'histoire nous
n'oublierons jamais l'escalade des glaciers de
Patagonie en sautant d'un avion à
10 000 pieds
qu'est-ce que tu lui donnes à manger, de quoi tu
parles, je m'en prends à toi, il n'aime pas
ça jusqu'à ce que tu apparaisses, c'est le
Doug que je connais,
tu ne trouves pas que c'est un peu étrange que le
nom de ton témoin soit BIC Mitchum
I  dois-je être honnête avec vous, les gars,
dites-le